[Música]
continuamos con nuestro programa y con
la revista de prensa de rosa pérez de
rosa un saludo para usted los buenos
días y las noticias de lucha inundan a
esta hora en las portadas de los medios
internacionales buenos dias angela
exactamente hoy encontramos en
muchísimos medios de comunicación hemos
hecho una selección de cinco periódicos
que destacan pues a lo que está dejando
ver la retirada de las tropas rusas de
los suburbios de la capital ucraniana de
kiev vemos aquí en la república este
medio italiano que titula el horror
debuta con esta imagen que hemos visto
en muchísimas portadas hay muchísimas
portadas una imagen de eso ahora ven
siembra para writers y pasamos a the
times este medio del reino unido que
dice civiles ejecutados en las calles no
dice pues que los rusos que están en
retirada están siendo acusados de
genocidio y que las víctimas civiles que
se encuentran en las calles de lucha de
este suburbio
ucraniano pues que algunas de ellas
tenían las manos maniatadas
en el estilo de una ejecución según este
medio británico pasamos por otro lado a
este medio alemán que va con la misma
imagen de portada de ronaldo cents para
a efe y que titulan el error sobre esta
masacre cerca de kiev pasamos al
'washington post' en eeuu que
destaca nuestra cita desde el ens cake
que califica pues en los crímenes de
rusia de genocidio la invasión rusa de
genocidio y cerramos con la nación de
argentina que a pesar de que no lleva
esto en su principal titular también lo
destaca en la portada indignación global
por el horror en mucha pero además vamos
a destacar la portada del monte con un
punto de inflexión en la guerra en
ucrania esto es lo que opina este medio
francés no dice que el descubrimiento de
los cadáveres civiles en los alrededores
de kiev marca como dices una ruptura en
este conflicto dice que para los
europeos y en realidad pues para
cualquiera que mire las noticias
alrededor del mundo
son normales las imágenes de civiles
atrincherados de hospitales bombardeados
y de soldados muertos en combate sin
embargo dicen toda guerra hay una
batalla más sanguinaria que las otras
que provoca un electroshock de la
opinión pública y este sería el caso de
muchas de estas imágenes que estamos
viendo pues de esta ciudad ucraniana
dice sin embargo la indignación no es
suficiente en relación a las palabras
del presidente francés emmanuel macrón o
del canciller alemán olaf scholz dice
que ahora que la unión europea va a
revisar la aplicación de posibles nuevas
sanciones que pueden estar relacionadas
como comentabas con el carbón y el
petróleo es momento de que la decisión o
la posición de la unión europea deje de
ser gradual y que sea de una vez por
todas contundente de hecho este medio
acaba preguntándose tenemos que esperar
a ver una nueva carnicería en mariupol
para definitivamente aplicar sanciones
al gas bueno probablemente no es tanto
cuestión de ver una carnicería en
mariupol sino después encontrar una
alternativa para distintos países
europeo es no angela pero es una
dependencia de la que estábamos hablando
durante el noticiero y que hemos venido
reportando durante todas estas semanas
de la guerra putin se repliega o al
menos eso dice la editorial del país
exactamente es también pues otro medio
que lleva en su opinión del día pues un
comentario sobre la situación de la
invasión rusa de ucrania dice que la
retirada es un hecho y que ha sembrado
todo el horror que empiezan a mostrar
las imágenes de la ciudad de butch a
cadáveres de civiles abandonados en
carreteras caminos y edificios dice por
más que la retórica del kremlin sea la
redistribución de tropas para
concentrarlas en el donbass es evidente
pues que rusia no está desarrollando
esta guerra como le gustaría dice que
los ritmos pues de la ofensiva siempre
son una incógnita pero que esta guerra
relámpago que ya dura 40 días pues es
evidente que pues se está creando
ciertas dificultades dificultades para
el kremlin y que sea como sea la
resolución de este conflicto va a pasar
por la ciudad de mariupol como
comentábamos que es la pieza que le
faltaba a putin para unir las repúblicas
y lugares con la anexada crimea y
rápidamente como reportan los medios
rusos tanto conservamos que ya prada
como rt reproducen esta retórica del
kremlin de que pues estos crímenes en
lucha habrían sido cometidos por grupos
neonazis destacan a que los cadáveres no
sean pues reportado hasta cuatro días
después de que se fuera el último
soldado ruso de las afueras de kiev y
que por lo tanto se trataría de un
montaje del gobierno ucraniano
precisamente para provocar lo que
estamos viendo hoy y es que los medios
occidentales pues lleven estos crímenes
en sus portadas y que se interrumpan así
las negociaciones de paz de hecho hasta
incluso védomosti dice que el gobierno
ruso y la justicia rusa investigarán a
los periodistas tanto de la espe como de
reuters como a pues las personas
involucradas del gobierno de kiev
implicadas en esta operación de
comunicación y para terminar angela pues
hemos preparado y alentamos a cualquier
que quiera a ver las imágenes que están
presentes en muchísimos medios de
comunicación hemos señalado en este caso
el país y el kiev independent que llevan
unas fotogalerías muy explícitas eso sí
pues son un testigo pues muy crudo de
las imágenes que se pueden ver en esta
ciudad pero pues que cada uno entre las
vea y saque pues sus propias
conclusiones y decir que no están
recomendados para menores hoy gracias a
ustedes rosa por toda la información y
el momento de pasar a nuestro invitado
del día